this past summer the Supreme Court
overturned nearly 50 years of
affirmative action and college
admissions it's not just the craziness
of our College institutions it's also
the Looney Birds over at the view and
they had uh the Department of Education
Secretary Miguel Cardona on and well
you're not going to believe it he also
thinks that America's racist the Supreme
Court is evil and the rest of it and
here he is with the noted racist herself
sunny
hustin but let me ask you this in terms
of inclusivity this past summer this
Supreme Court overturn nearly 50 years
of affirmative action and college
admissions and you called recently that
a new low point and warned quote in
danger we are in danger of a new Jim
Crow era in some parts of this country
are we already seeing the effects of
that decision and and in your view how
long will the impact last look we cannot
rest until the diversity on our campuses
reflects the beautiful diversity of our
country that's what makes this country
special yeah
and unfortunately we're not there and
the Supreme Court decision in my opinion
took us a step backward but what I am
seeing are college presidents doubling
down they're recruiting better they're
engaging with K12 institutions we have
an opportunity to really go better than
what the affirmative action results are
uh we need to hold ourselves accountable
and we need to remind colleges that we
want our children to go to schools where
they're going to learn with people that
are different than
them these are these are such bad people
and the fact that the view audience this
is Upper West Side New York City these
are all white liberals oh my God it's so
great affirmative action you idiots do
you realize it's your children that will
not get into schools your children who
you put all the money to put them in
private schools and you did everything
right with family and all that other
stuff well sorry they're white so
they're just not going to get into
schools anymore the reversal of course
and they're talking about the Supreme
Court reversal of affirmative action
related to college and missions which
happened a few months ago of course was
right we are supposed to be a colorblind
Society why is it forget the Jews right
it used to be Harvard and the Ivy League
schools were always discriminating
against the Jews because Jews cared
about education and family and hard work
so there were too many Jews at Cornell
too many Jews at Harvard this is a fact
so they used to discriminate against
Jews but it has moved on from the
colleges are obviously done with the
Jews now they openly discriminate
against Asian kids because Asian kids
and it doesn't matter whether they're
Japanese Chinese Korean whatever
generally speaking their culture leads
them to working hard tiger mom right you
might say that's a little bit overboard
and maybe they should be playing sports
more instead of studying eight hours a
day but the the overall feeling of the
culture is one of hard work and
dedication and meritocracy and all those
things and what he wants and what racist
Sunny hon want is people to get in based
on the color of their skin and of course
what that does over time is grades the
entire system so if you have a young kid
who gets into let's say a a high school
like a private high school not because
he deserves to be there because of the
work that he's put in and everything
else but because of his skin color now
he gets into a college because of his
skin color now he gets into grad school
because of his skin color then he gets
the job because of skin color etc etc
eventually our doctors will not know how
to perform heart surgery our Pilots will
not know how to fly and you will be an
idiot if you don't want a white doctor
you will want a white doctor because the
doctors that are white will have had to
work the hardest and been the most
qualified to get the freaking job in the
first place I'm getting cancelled for
that one Dave Rubin only wants white
doctors